over the weekend I had a few
conversations with the hosts of
progressive independent shows like the
David Pakman show and unfortunately the
topic of discussion was that we are all
seeing a bit of a decline in support for
our programs and what we saw right after
Donald Trump was elected in November of
2016 was a massive increase in the
number of people becoming members of our
shows becoming patreon donors to our
shows and initially this was catalyzed
by the atrocities of the election of
Donald Trump and the sort of early
policy decisions of his administration a
lot of progressive independent shows in
April and May of 2017 were further
bolstered by YouTube ad pocalypse where
many of our YouTube channels suffered as
much as 99% decreases in ad revenue so
from about November of 2016 through
about September of last year
there were just massive increases to the
number of people supporting independent
progressive media shows like the David
Pakman show I don't want to say exactly
which other shows I'm talking about
because I didn't tell them I'm gonna
mention by the way that I spoke to you
but you can imagine who they are right
people know who it is that I talk to
people know who the Friends of the show
are and what we've all noticed is that
starting in April right so about two
three months ago there have been some
issues and I spoke to the other show
hosts and everybody is experiencing
something very very similar which is
that we are seeing a sort of waning of
patreon support if you look at our
patreon page and other show patreon
pages you will see the number of
pledgers of patrons has been sort of
trickling down we're currently in the
middle of a free speech TV pledge drive
the pledge drive had to be extended as
you know Pat because of slow fundraising
this is not about one show this is a
systemic problem and I think that there
are three issues that are going on here
number one hyper normalization has led
to waning support for progressive
independent media because people are on
four
starting to get the mindset that you
know what this is how it is Trump saying
suspend due process for undocumented
immigrants it's just not feeling that
crazy because there have been another
another hundred crazy things in the last
three months hyper normalization is
affecting the right but it is also
affecting the left and I believe it is
leading directly to the detriment of
independent progressive media number two
net neutrality
the repeal of Obama era net neutrality
rules has happened and that is going to
be a further systemic threat to
progressive independent media and then
number three media consolidation which
is very clear it has been made
abundantly clear will be welcomed under
the current administration and Justice
Department with the purchase of AT&T by
AT&T of Time Warner approved I think it
was early last week that we did that
story we've experienced it patreon is
trailing off a lot of the memberships
that swelled last year from D
monetization it's been a year a lot of
those people's credit cards have expired
and their memberships are not being
renewed and this is a really bad
direction and it's really fundamentally
a question of what you want if the
demand that there was for independent
progressive media when Donald Trump was
elected when the marches were happening
when D monetization hit if the demand
for independent progressive media wanes
then independent progressive media will
also Wayne in combination with net
neutrality being repealed with media
consolidation continuing that is not a
good direction that is not the way I
want to see it go if instead we can
refocus and realize hey you know what
our cable bills are about to go up
because of what's going on with net
neutrality and internet slow lanes and
fast lanes we are increasingly if we
turn on our TV going to get our news
from an increasingly narrow scope and
point of view because of that media
consolidation and we don't want that the
path forward is very clear and we often
sugarcoat pad and we use all
sorts of different language to talk
about support this and support that
independent progressive media will not
survive if it is not supported and we
have two ways for you to do that and I
am sort of reinvigorating my commitment
to grow the space of support number one
just make a small pledge on patreon okay
this we're not asking for a lot of money
if a hundred and thirty eight people
pledge $1 a month we will hit our goal
of two thousand patrons just go to
patreon.com/scishow pledge a dollar okay
we now have a bunch of free stuff
available with patreon pledges bumper
stickers t-shirts discount codes for
gear the bonus show the full show pledge
a dollar okay and number two the
steadfast supporter of the program has
been and continues to be membership and
if you go to david pakman.com slash
membership i don't care if you use the
coupon code and save 40 percent that
coupon code is vote soon 18 whatever you
can contribute whether it's a dollar or
whether it's the big boy membership on
our website of 480 dollars for the year
whatever you can do do it because all of
the shows like ours are starting to see
it's scary pat and it is the
normalization of what is going on
everybody's used to what's going on it's
a multi-pronged problem race media
consolidation hyper normalization net
neutrality right yes so we need a
multi-pronged solution i like that and
that's membership that's patreon and so
many other things too complex problems
require complex solutions although
that's not even really true it's not
complex at all to just go to patreon and
make a pledge of $1.00 or to go to our
website and to sign up for a membership
we will be restarting the YouTube live
streams that I was doing some time ago I
am gonna be recommitting to that so
we've got to make it happen because the
next six months up to and just past the
midterms and then we've got 2020 like
2020 is just around the corner I can
assure you that we will not like the
results if independent progressive media
is not supported quick break
pseudoscience miniseries episode 1
preview coming up next